[Music]
what's the first Super Bowl you covered
uh the first one that was here in
Houston because the worldwide leader I
couldn't crack the football lineup
oh I never cracked the football and it
went the mothership No so the first one
I covered was the first Super Bowl here
in Houston which was well with the
Patriots obviously I think it was one
with Rice University years ago but um
with a soda right so uh Brady
Belichick the dome John we do Sports
Center that night together after the
game I did add imagine NFL Network that
night so maybe I don't think you had me
on no I remember I did collars postgame
show for Super Bowl in the history of
the NFL Network it was me Solomon
Wilkinson to director's chairs in the
end zone of then Reliant Stadium and I
remember Bob Kraft came by with the
Lombardi Trophy and Belichick who was
kind enough to come on Total Access
earlier in the week as a guest on a on a
Tuesday night he actually showed up we
thought we would get him postgame too
but he went straight to Berman you're
your guest later on in this hour or next
hour and then he went to Birmingham and
went to the bus so you never covered a
Super Bowl for the mothership never oh
okay no I did the the baseball circuit
for for the mothership okay world series
etc etc but never superable why ever got
to work on an NFL show at the mothership
but I did do SportsCenter quite a few
super well you might have might have
been the fort holder in Bristol okay
Ossining to you on several Super Sunday
some of the great throws ever in TV
history at night sure we go back to Dan
in Houston yeah back when split screens
were just one person standing there and
the other person throwing to them
instead of barking at each other with a
hashtag on a topic bar we were talking
about media night
now it's media night yes where we where
are we headed with this what I mean
where we headed with this like what's
what's coming down the road well they
knew this kid this is look I want one of
the many things that Roger Goodell said
when he took over as the Commissioner
was let's look at everything and and see
how things can be improved or not
everything is this sacred cow just
because it's been that way forever
so the Pro Bowl as we all know was moved
to before the Super Bowl and the draft
went
from two days on a weekend to two nights
and a weekend day
now the hall-of-fame game is going to be
played before the actual ceremony
the commissioners press conference moves
from friday to wednesday these are all
changes that I've seen that nobody ever
thought would ever happen just because
it was done in a certain way and then
look I mean why would you want to have a
media day in the middle of a work day on
a Tuesday when you could kick off a week
with a prime-time event that you know
some might roll their eyes at but you
know it was an event it's something that
is event eyes everybody's trying to do
that in any sport and the NFL is no
different
yeah the only thing I'd like to see is
the fans get in free like like just have
one thing where you're saying to the
host fanbase sure you get in free they
charged admission line I honestly did
not know I believe so but I would also
like to see young young kids I like to
see whether high school kids great grade
school kids get an opportunity to do so
do something to do an interview be great
I think that maybe that's what they
should do is get a kid at each podium
and that's the first question that's
asked before the scrum hits that's not a
bad idea at all you know that some local
Houstonians or people from around the
area here in Texas get the first
question I think that that'd be great
well because we complain you know if
middle-aged guys are complaining like
this you know we can't get any good at
you know interviews if you let a 12 year
old ask a question to Tom Brady or Bill
Belichick you might get a better answer
than we're going to get and it would
mean something and if you have the fans
there and you want to have a musical
guest like just do something where it
feels positive for everybody also just
in this day and age dan when when when
players have their own platform to get
out their information whether it's a
Twitter account or an illegal Facebook
liveing after a playoff game we know
more about these players than ever
before and as opposed to just Monday
night we're also going to get a media
availability some today then Wednesday
then Thursday so if somebody doesn't get
their question in I don't know how
that's possible during a Super Bowl week
if they are credentialed for all of the
events and nobody's going to get any
serious work done on a
Monday night when there's a fake Brady
walking around or somebody dressed as a
you know the Blue Man Group I mean that
that's that's not what Monday night is
about it is about a spectacle more than
anything else
Rich Eisen joining us on loan from the
NFL Network and the Rich Eisen show
DIRECTV are we prepared for the Patriots
losing hmm I don't think so I don't
think this country is prepared you know
on on my show down the down the hall we
have a daily segment we've been doing
for a week now that your daily reminder
that the Atlanta Falcons are also at
Super Bowls if you want yeah because
even all of the Falcons main storylines
Dan Quinn's previous Super Bowl
experience and also the people who put
this roster together or where Matt Ryan
went to college the through line is
still through the Patriots that they
either lost to the Patriots in the
previous Super Bowl like Dan Quinn or
the people who shop for the groceries
for Atlanta did it for New England or
Matt Ryan is going to maybe deny Tom
Brady in that New England area Super
Bowl when he went to Boston College etc
etc etc it's tough to find a Falcon
storyline that has nothing to do with
New England even the fact that how well
Matt Ryan's played and how great this
offense is we're all talking about it as
the this could be the toughest team the
Patriots have faced in a Super Bowl so
all of it is about the way New England
is viewed through Atlanta so I don't
think people are prepared I think they
absolutely can win the Super Bowl and
and and they could win it convincingly
it is entirely possible that that
happens in a way that I don't think
folks could have seen previous Super
Bowls play out that way for New England
I also find it amusing when somebody
says oh the Patriots are on mission
you know they really want to win this
Super Bowl as if Atlanta says yeah you
know I'm sort of ambivalent you know if
we win and win it was just like what are
we saying here
we're just happy to be here Billy got a
great line last week when he was talking
about well everybody says Bill Belichick
takes the one thing away that he knows
that can beat you goes well the rest of
us coaches what are we taking away the
decoys you know I guess that's what
we're doing we're going into it we're
going to take away those decoys you know
just the way we talk about these things
Sean halls very much on
last hour and we were talking about
Brady and he said if Brady wins this is
Brady does then Brady move into a
different category of greatest football
player of all time because if you
decorate him with all these Super Bowls
five right and let's say when is another
MVP can he be the great because not fair
yet you don't think he's they're the
greatest football player of all time if
you want to start naming them obviously
go Jenny brown Jerry Rice and there's
three other spots if you have a top five
yeah who else are you choosing here I
mean but I think we will get caught up
in that he's not a great athlete in the
sense of what you know Lauren Taylor did
or Jim Brown did or Jerry Rice and I
think that's where it's hard when
somebody says Oh greatest athlete of all
time well I think we're still holding
his combine run antique against that all
these years laters which is why that
fire burns so deep within him said he
wants to win he wants the whole Brady's
physique against him is that right all
day every day no shame there's nothing
else to hold against to mentor young
he's one he's pretty much won everything
this is what my my crew did last night
Paulie stood next to Jimmy Garoppolo not
to interview him but just to see how
handsome he was it's not creepy at all
now and we have a picture of Paulie
where he's just lurking over Jimmy
Garoppolo shoulder like a proud father
working as a crime admiring okay I just
soaking it in no I really I think we
need to unpack this a little bit more
Syrian Air alert right there just there
staring it
James Garoppolo I mean I'm looking at
the photograph right now I mean it's
sort of a you know creepy most not sort
of it's completely created haha yeah I
wanted to see would he'd say you know if
you talk about trade stuff he shook it
off nicely
like a veteran already talk any trade so
okay but and that is just soaking in the
looks the transition from Brady to grow
out below from a look standpoint you
guys never break that down on anything
you think that'll be a smooth transition
absolutely looks was yeah looks wide
yeah other people in New England hot add
hot look well not not to make this a a
hot take or as you would call a warm
take of any sort I don't I don't know if
James G is going to be around next year
I think I think where is he
that's the million dollar question I
don't know but I don't think he's on New
England okay if you're Cleveland would
you take Jim Garoppolo Oranje Sean wants
it or Mitch true Biscay
I love deshaun Watson I think he's
getting nut you not to sound like Dabo
Swinney but I think he's going to be a
major star in the NFL but I hope he
doesn't go to Cleveland just because we
know what happens when you go to
Cleveland now Dan I mean at some point
you know that's going to change right I
mean I challenge for the Cavs it's how
many you got how many decades if we buy
in talking about it but how many
quarterbacks have gone there and then we
never hear from right well when was last
time I drafted one was a Tim Couch and
Whedon right and then who else on him
until well as Brady Joanne oh my god
you're right he should be so hopeless
here I'm going down I think he's a
difference maker of the first variety
but Garoppolo I would be I would be what
would you rather suppose to take him I
mean how many and how many players and
and I don't want to bring that up
specifically because we are here in
Houston just because they they started
six seven games for somebody else let's
pay them in absurd amount of money and
think that they could start a football
game for us I haven't seen any oppelo
that I go all in my way I've seen more
from Watson than I have dropped wow
you've you've seen who's faced with
tougher defenses I would say okay I mean
I would this is all due respect to
Arizona
yeah but Arizona and the first game of
the year wasn't up to the previous year
snuff that Alabama defense I know I'm
comparing Arizona's defense to Alabama's
but Alabama is as close to Pro ready as
you can get and deshaun Watson took hits
in two major big games against these
guys and damn near one on both so I
would take watching over Garoppolo I
really would just to see about it by the
way how much for the tickets to media
night okay so you can get them for
twenty up to thirty at field level $20
okay so they did charge people yeah
people wanted her to get in there Rich
Eisen show on Direct TV audience Network
noon Eastern who's on the show today um
Michael Irvin Kurt Warner Warren Moon
Shawn O'Hara and the ice Williams in all
three hours j.b smoove who is the Rich
Eisen show media night car
respondent for a third straight year
breaking things Olli Paulie said that he
was how do you do
he Randall up he ran the room players
were coming to him to talk created a
ruckus that's what we're trying to do
the first day we were credentialing
Snoop Dogg he's going to both press
conferences for a second straight year
for sho gin and juice
yeah lays the haunted drop this are you
dropping it like a toe yeah okay I'm
very good sipping I like to drop it like
it's warm not like it's hot see you got
that that's why he goes against the
grain drop it like it's war that's right
right uh he's Rich Eisen taking this
game later on today thank you rich we'll
come back by the way of Ryan Leaf will
join is coming up Chris Berman at the
top of the hour here on the Dan Patrick
show the Dan Patrick show weekday
morning on audience
[Music]